i still can't believe it i'm gonna fall  in love with a new little person again  [Music]  just breathe  i'm gonna hang down from three  and on three  and two and one  [Music]  i can't lie to my family anymore  [Music]  the second you tell your wife that you  are dying  your opportunity to do this is gone  [Music]  you want to go say hi  [Music]  so he has everything even the memories  you store deep in your subconscious  do this with us and let life go on for  your family a clean swab  if love  what's going on  you have an opportunity here i'm not  done  you think i like this  being told i'm not me because you're not  me  you are not  [Music]  i love you cam antenna  [Music]  you